[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez más de un rosa bienvenida muy
buena mañana de miércoles vamos a abrir
entonces esta revista de prensa con un
repaso de los medios internacionales que
abren de forma unánime una visita en
annecy pelosi a taiwán así es raúl vemos
en muchísimas portadas esta imagen de
pelos y llegando a taipei y también en
palabras que se repiten o dentro de
varios titulares desafío crisis tensión
y como bien decía si bien de momento
esta visita no que ha generado pues eso
tanta tensión no ha tenido una
consecuencia
digamos a directa física podríamos decir
prácticamente entre beijing y washington
sí que son de estos episodios que sin
duda van forjando las relaciones
internacionales digamos de forma
irreversible y como ya bien decías
durante el noticiero ya tiene
consecuencias en el ámbito comercial si
bien vamos a comentar cinco titulares
que hemos seleccionado de la prensa
internacional
por el wall street journal que dice
pelosi visita a taiwán desafiando a
china y vemos la imagen de pelosi y al
lado los aviones los cazas del ejército
de china sobrevolando el estrecho de
taiwán continuamos con la nación de
argentina extrema presión tras la
llegada de pelosi a taiwán dice la
llegada de taiwán territorio reclamado
por china de la presidencia de la cámara
de representantes de eeuu hundió ayer en
una peligrosa crisis diplomática a
washington y pekín que amenazó con
acciones militares continuamos con el
país de cali de aquí de colombia que
dice pelos y avivó la tensión entre eeuu
y china y para continuar en la región
américa latina y el caribe vamos con el
granma de cuba que como ellos mismos se
definen son un órgano del partido
comunista cubano que
publican una declaración del ministerio
de relaciones exteriores que se titula
cuba reafirma el apoyo irrestricto al
principio de una sola china no por
supuesto la habana condena la visita de
pelosi a taiwán
quizás su preocupación por relaciones
entre washington y taipei en el
incremento por ejemplo de los contratos
militares y de las ventas de armas dice
además nuevas provocaciones disfrazadas
de visitas de alto nivel generan
peligros adicionales y concluye diciendo
q va a reafirmar el reconocimiento de
taiwán como parte inalienable del
territorio de china y cerramos este
repaso deportados internacionales con el
frankfurter allgemeine que dice beijing
quiere reaccionar militarmente al viaje
de pelosi a taiwán bueno rosa vamos
ahora con el 'global times' de china y
el taipei times de taiwán porque ellos
también abordan por supuesto esta
situación exactamente dice el 'global
times' este digamos órgano también del
partido comunista china podríamos chino
podríamos decir digamos muy oficialista
y ultranacionalista que dice esta vez
todo el mundo ha visto quién está
cambiando el status quo en el estrecho
de taiwán dice pelos y ha hecho oídos
sordos a las advertencias de china y
washington no ha hecho nada para y su
viaje a taiwán y dice no se sustenta por
ningún lugar el argumento de que hay una
separación de poderes digamos de que
biden es el parte del poder ejecutivo y
pelosi del legislativo dice esta visita
es una traición al compromiso político
de eeuu con china hay que advertir a
personas como pelosi que taiwán no es un
lugar que puedan visitar visitar como a
su voluntad no dice además la ruta del
avión que tomo pelosi muestra que voló
en círculos sobre el mar de china con
temor a que el ejército realizará
ejercicios con fuego real pelosi sintió
el peligro dice que además el momento
para reunir para lograr la reunificación
siempre va a estar en manos de beijing y
finalmente pues eso no que eeuu va a
acabar perdiendo la apuesta de apoyar a
taiwán y continuamos con el taipei times
que considera a pelosi una verdadera
amiga de taiwán y de los chinos
oprimidos y una compañera de armas en la
lucha contra la tiranía y la búsqueda de
la libertad
bueno rosa y cerramos esta revista de
prensa con noticias sobre la ley
reemplazo del primer ministro británico
boris johnson no tiene otra información
si muy rápidamente me gustaría comentar
una cuestión que hemos añadido el último
momento porque si bien digamos se
publicó ayer considerábamos importante
destacarlo dentro de esta revista de
prensa y es que cuando aterrizó pelosi
en taiwán ayer inmediatamente el
washington post publicó una un artículo
de opinión de pelosi que explicaba por
qué visita taiwán una un poco en la
línea de cuando by de na justificó
porque visitaba arabia saudí- salvando
todas las distancias no bien pelosi dice
que china se prepara para reunificar a
taiwán por la fuerza y que eeuu está con
taiwán su socio democrático y que junto
a taiwán van a defender la libertad
paradójicamente asegura que esto no
contradice el principio de una sola
china no sin embargo esta línea de la
ambigüedad estratégica cada vez es cada
vez es digamos menos ambigua y parece
que digamos es piensa cada vez más está
cuerda por otro lado pelosi también
justifica su paso por taiwán un poco
común pasaba por aquí
dice que su gira pues recuerda que
incluía a singapur malasia japón y a
corea del sur y pues que taiwán
prácticamente le quedaba cerca como si
no fuera nada del otro mundo pues
tratarse de la máxima representante
estadounidense en pisar taiwán en 25
años y ella misma recuerda un episodio
al que también hace referencia la bbc en
un artículo que repasa la trayectoria
antichina de pelosi se trata de cuando
hace 30 años pelosi con una delegación
del congreso de eeuu se plantó en la
plaza de tiananmen y desplegó una
pancarta que ponía por los que mueren
defendiendo la democracia en china y
bien en una digamos una línea de
argumentación lógica un poco confusa
pero si dice como en ese momento hoy en
día beijing continúa reprimiendo a hong
kong en el tíbet en xinjiang y también
dentro de la china continental y dice
acá va juntando esta represión con la
invasión rusa de ucrania y dice tal y
como le dije hace y siempre estaremos
del lado de la democracia y nunca
cederemos ante los autócratas bien una
argumentación como decimos un poco
confusa y para terminar el raúl muy
rápidamente con lo que me preguntaba es
rápidamente
efectivamente parece que se va a
posponer la elección adentro del partido
conservador para encontrar un sustituto
de boris johnson como líder del partido
y como primer ministro por amenazas de
hackeo y según una primera encuesta
publicada por the times parece que
listas va liderando esta intención de
voto con un 60% del partido conservador
a favor rosa como siempre muchísimas
gracias por esta revista de prensa
mañana con más pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer visitaba el día para
sigue hablando esta visita de pelosi
está igual